with the queen's death fortunes as well
as titles passed down the line of
succession so it's worth reminding
ourselves where the money comes from the
royal family is funded by three main
revenue streams the sovereign grant the
largest which was worth 86 million
pounds last year and the duchy of
lancaster worth 22 million pounds both
of which will fund the king and the
duchy of cornwall worth 24 million
pounds which will now fund william as
heir and prince of wales now the
sovereign grant is drawn from revenue
generated by the crown estate a 15
billion pound portfolio of property and
land three quarters of which goes to the
exchequer and the rest to pay for the
crown and while it was worth 86 million
pounds last year the queen spent 102
million let's have a look at how that
breaks down 64 million pounds was spent
on maintaining the royal palaces almost
50 million of that went on the
refurbishment of buckingham palace 27.5
million went on paying almost 500
members of staff four and a half million
on travel and more than three million on
gas and electricity the king also gets
revenue from the 600 million pound duchy
of lancaster estate that was worth 22
million pounds last year which the queen
used to fund core members of the family
including princess anne prince andrew
and prince edward now the king will only
pay income tax on this if like his
mother he volunteers to
as prince of wales william will enjoy
the surplus from the 1 billion pound
duchy of cornwall estate that includes
the oval cricket ground and was worth 24
million pounds last year it is exempt
from corporation tax and capital gains
tax and income tax will again be
voluntary
now as the presumed main beneficiary of
his mother's will the king will also
inherit immense private wealth including
sandringham and balmoral the queen owned
privately as part of an estate worth an
estimated 350 million pounds but the
detail
will remain private as uniquely royal
wills do not have to go to probate as
the process by which they become public
and the king will not pay inheritance
tax gifts from monarch to monarch are
exempt
and there's a small matter of more than
a dozen palaces and residences around
the country six of them in london plus
windsor castle are publicly maintained
but he also has homes in gloucestershire
wales and burke hall up in scotland plus
the inherited balmoral and sandringham
in norfolk
royal funding is a deal between the
palace and parliament and by association
the public but king charles ascending in
a cost of living crisis may face greater
scrutiny than his mother of what is
appropriate for a modern monarch and
what counts as excess